ron it's actually not that serious i
just need you to stay calm okay
yeah i'm just gonna stay angry i find
that relaxes me
and i'll have the number eight that's a
party platter serves 12 people
i know what i'm about son and
one number eight all right party time i
would suggest sticking around and
watching him eat it cause it only takes
four minutes and it's pretty amazing
these will not be necessary
i got a second box of donuts if anybody
what the hell is this this mr director
is your new desk okay excuse me
there's a sign at ramps at park that
says do not drink the sprinkler water
so i made sun tea with it and now i have
an infection
sir sir are are
are you listening to me sir sir i'm
talking to you
sir sir are you aware
that there is waste in your water system
i would prefer that she asked me for my
permission
so i can say no i like saying no
it lowers their enthusiasm
on my deathbed my final wish is to have
my
ex-wives rush to my side so i can use my
dying breath to tell them both to go to
hell one last time
would i get married again oh absolutely
if you don't believe in love what's the
point of living
i gotta tell you ron you were absolutely
and totally right i know stop talking
and get out
yup
all told we were in there about six
hours
and no i was not meditating i just stood
there quietly breathing
there were no thoughts in my head
whatsoever my mind was blank
i don't know what the hell these other
crackpots are doing
well i've never been one for meeting new
people or doing
new things or eating new types of food
or traveling outside of southern indiana
i've had the same haircut since 1978 and
have driven the same car
since 1991 i've used the same wooden
comb for three decades
i have one bowl nutrium's energy bars
are just
absolutely loaded with high fructose
corn syrup and fatty oils and any way
you slice it they're just
extremely unhealthy for you leslie needs
to butt out
the whole point of this country is if
you want to eat garbage
balloon up to 600 pounds and i have a
heart attack at 43
you can you are free to do so to me
that's beautiful the less i know about
other people's affairs
the happier i am i'm not interested in
caring about people
i once worked with a guy for three years
and never learned his name
best friend i ever had
we still never talk sometimes normally
if given a choice between doing
something and nothing i choose to do
nothing
but i will do something if it helps
someone else do nothing i'd work
all night if it meant nothing got done
larry salami
the human resources department requires
that i be available once a month to
discuss
workplace disputes with my employees the
rules do not specify whether or not i'm
allowed to listen to willie nelson on my
headphones
and kyle parked his car in my spot again
now that is the fourth time this month
[Music]
he's proud hello go for you
today i just want to choke him until he
passes out
hi ron i ron
ladies ladies
[Applause]
hmm
thank you all for being here let's get
started
wow great attitude ron
sorry i was talking to these ribs okay
so the valentine's day dance is hey anne
if you get this i don't know if you
should come
up here he's not worth it okay just call
me let me know where you are
ron what in the devil's name is this
portobello mushrooms where's the steak
oh there's no steak that's a healthier
option it's organically grown
you okay whoa whoa okay can you get us a
cold compress or something
just give me the ip address of the dude
that gave me that cracked out yelp
review
okay here we go the ip dress says it
came from someone inside city hall
in this building oh hell no well who
cares really it's just some dumb
internet person
ignore it ignore it i'm about to calm
down on this dude like thor's hammer
mjolnir
i'm about to go mjolnir on his ass
speaking of bad reviews computers are
mostly
pointless but that yelp thing gave me a
great idea
on how to criticize people and places
i am composing strongly worded letters
about things i disapprove
of and i am using the internet to get
addresses where i can send them
so far i've written to a vegetable farm
several european ambassadors
a manufacturer of male cologne and a
non-fat
frozen yogurt bar dear frozen yogurt you
are the celery of desserts
be ice cream or be nothing zero stars
third time today
that's a good shoeshine
what the [ __ ] man i i don't know
what happened frankly anne was getting a
little chummy
when people get too chummy with me i
like to call them by the wrong name to
let them know i don't really care about
them
that's a genius move thank you you're
welcome
lester
the key to burning an ex-wife effigy is
to dip it in paraffin wax
and then toss the flaming bottle of
isopropyl alcohol
from a safe distance do not stand too
close
when you light an ex-wife effigy hey
what about you mr uh a man's word is
sacred
well it is but you're an ass hey ron
you're not gonna slaughter that pig here
are you not to worry
i have a permit
this just says i can do what i want i am
the director of the parks department and
this is a park
it's not a parks thing it's against like
three laws and a dozen health codes
just so you know it's not your typical
bar they specialize in
molecular mixology it's kind of like uh
an experimental new way to consume
alcohol
son there's no wrong way to consume
alcohol
[Music]
here's your bud light i ordered a beer
that is beer
and here's your nimbus martini may i go
ahead and chisel your aromasphere
please
this is the wrong way to consume alcohol
whoa that's a pretty stiff cloud
quarter of the scotch right here hold
out your hands please
what's happening oh this is a sort of
play on scotch
it's a whiskey infused lotion can i ask
if this entire establishment is a
practical joke of some kind
ron swanson it is my pleasure to inform
you
that you are a finalist for the job of
assistant city manager
chris i feel i should remind you that i
do not believe that the position or the
entire government
should exist that said you'd be a fool
not to pick me
i will walk deeper into the belly of the
beast if it means i'm able to further
limit reckless government spending
i mean i have so many ideas some are
simple like
take down traffic lights and eliminate
the post office
the bigger ones will be tougher like
bring all of this crumbling to the
ground
this isn't a stake why would you call it
that on your menu
i don't know what to tell you man
just give me all the bacon and eggs you
have
wait wait i worry what you just heard
was
give me a lot of bacon and eggs what i
said was
give me all the bacon and eggs you have
do you understand
every year i give leslie the same
present i give everyone
a crisp 20 bill and every year she gets
me
something thoughtful and personal it
makes me furious
this year she outdid herself
she had it installed over the weekend
it's so so beautiful
you